hi I'm Colleen Cavanaugh I'm a professor
in the Department of organismic and
evolutionary biology at Harvard
University and the co-director of the
microbial sciences initiative today I'm
going to tell you about this discovery
of chemosynthetic symbiosis these are
intimate associations between bacteria
and marine invertebrates that allow both
partners to colonize and thrive in
otherwise inhospitable environments the
discovery of these symbiosis followed on
the discovery of the deep sea
hydrothermal vents and the communities
that flourish around these but finding
the symbiosis at the vents also
highlighted that these occur in other
habitats such as coastal sediments that
have a lot of sulfide so today what I'm
going to do is first provide you with
some background on symbiosis on
chemosynthesis the basis of these
symbiotic associations on the
hydrothermal events and then on my
academic paths through this adventure so
symbiosis was the term was coined by
Anton de Bary to mean
the living together of differently named
organisms these are associations with
benefit to at least one of the partners
and as examples there are corals which
have intracellular photosynthetic algae
that feed them legumes that form
symbiosis with nitrogen-fixing bacteria
so effectively there's self-fertilizing
chloroplasts and mitochondria in our
cells and plants which evolve from free
living bacteria and of course recently
we know about the human microbiome
there's been a lot of work in the last
seven eight years and the impact that
your own bacteria those within your gut
on your skin and all over your body have
on the development of your immune system
nutrition neurobiology the list goes on
and on so symbiosis is an incredibly
important aspect of biology so the
common theme here for these symbiosis
and one of the main processes is co2
fixation carbon fixation is
typically we think of it by plants which
is via photosynthesis this is taking
carbon dioxide out of the air and
turning it into sugars and in plants you
use light to fuel that operation in
bacteria that are capable of
chemosynthesis they use inorganic
compounds such as hydrogen sulfide iron
hydrogen and oxidize these compounds to
produce the energy that is then used to
fix co2 in the same processes as
photosynthesis hc' hydrothermal vents
are ecosystems on the seafloor they were
discovered in 1977 in association with
the search and study of seafloor
spreading essentially these are hot
springs that are associated with
volcanic activity along the ocean ridges
you can see in the top photographs that
these ridges circle the Earth like seams
on a baseball these are areas where the
seafloor is spreading there's a lot of
volcanic activity sea water percolates
down into the the deep ocean or the sub
floor is heated chemically charged with
compounds and then is forced up through
other fissures as you can see on the
bottom photo with the so called black
smoker and around these communities
around these vents are these lush
communities of tubeworms clams mussels
shrimp with biomass that rivals that of
the rainforest this totally
revolutionize revolutionized our
perceptions of life in the deep sea
typically it was thought to be very very
sparse because food from the surface
photosynthesis wouldn't make it down and
this so it was really how is this
working
bringing up samples of seawater and some
of the first cruises by geologists they
noted that it was smelled very strongly
of hydrogen sulfide and it was proposed
that bacteria using such compounds could
be the base of the food chain here via
chemosynthesis
as you'll see from the rest of the talk
in addition to free living bacteria
supporting these ecosystems symbiosis is
prevalent and in fact the dominant form
of carbon fixation at the vents so
my path to chemosynthesis & symbiosis in
the deep sea started at the University
of Michigan I'm from Detroit and went to
Michigan and there was a marine ecology
course offered at the Marine Biological
lab by three Michigan professors it was
a Michigan course we had two we had two
weeks of lectures and then had to design
our own project and to me it was
incredible that I learned that not
everything is known the textbooks aren't
always right and I fell in love with
research and I fell in love with Woods
Hole and managed to work out so that I
could come back after graduating at
Michigan then I worked at the ecosystem
center with John hobby and during this
time I was basically in a darkroom
looking in a microscope the whole day
all summer
counting bacteria he had developed a
method using fluorescence microscopy for
actually being able to count bacteria in
the real world that are too small to be
able to be seen with a light microscope
so it was a very revolutionary period of
time numbers of bacteria in the world I
then went to Harvard to graduate school
my plan was to work on coastal and open
ocean nutrient cycling as this was part
of the research that I was doing when I
was in Woods Hole so this brings me to
Harvard as a first year graduate student
I was taking a class called bio 255
nature and regulation of marine
ecosystems it was basically professors
three professors that offered it they
talked about their own research and then
they brought people in to talk to the
students and because the vents had only
been discovered recently we had a series
of talks on them and the first was on
the ecology by Ruth Turner a professor
in my department the second was on
chemistry by Russ Macduff who is a
chemist at MIT working on beds the third
was on microbiology Holder Janish was
from Woods Hole from the Woods Hole
Oceanographic Institute
I knew him there and he talked about the
presume microbiology
chemosynthesis being the base of the
food chain a lot about sulfur bacteria
iron bacteria and many others last we
had Meredith Jones the curator of worms
from the Smithsonian Institution he came
and he basically was a nostalgia stand a
taxonomist and in class he described
these two work two worms seen in this
picture which can get up to over a metre
in length and it turns out very peculiar
Lee they did not have a mouth or a gun
and so the big question was how do they
feed and essentially there's smaller
relatives that could take out dissolved
organic carbon across their epidermis
but these were so big it was thought the
surface to volume ratio was much too
small and the concentration of organic
carbon at these vents was low so
amazingly he was basically describing
the to worm section-by-section through a
1 meter 2 worm and I was still awake
when he came to this slide and this is
the so-called trophy some tissue this is
the tissue that fills the selamat cavity
of these tube worms it's a brown spongy
tissue it was named trophy Somme in
previous descriptions because it has the
gonads embedded in it and the tissue was
thought to feed the developing eggs in
the developing sperm so he mentioned he
showed this picture in the in during the
talk and he if you look in the back
that's a millimeter ruler so this is a
regular photograph and he mentioned that
he saw all these crystals and he had
them analyzed and it turned out they
were pure elemental sulphur it was at
this point where I jumped up and said
well it's perfectly clear they have a
symbiotic association with these
chemosynthetic bacteria that live inside
of them and then they feed the animal
just like dinoflagellates the algae and
corals feed their corals he said no no
we think it's a detoxifying organ and I
said well that's perfect because these
back
Karia can oxidize sulphide to elemental
sulfur and render it less toxic or not
toxic and then still fix co2 and feed
the to work so after the talk I was able
to convince dr. Jones to send me some
tissue and that I would prove there were
bacteria there indeed I thought it was a
done deal I thought it was a given but I
actually had to go through jump through
many hoops to try to prove that there
were bacteria in this tissue now I might
mention I had never had a microbiology
course and I had worked for John hobby
almost well over a year plus so I had a
love of bacteria but I was looking at
the majority of which could never be
cultured so really jumping in at a a
basic level I had done scanning electron
microscopy which is a method to be able
to look at tissues at higher
magnification and you see on this higher
upper figure this is a scanning um of
the trophy some tissue which is very low
Bueller and what I did was took a piece
of tape and pulled off a little bit of
the surface and if you look closely
you'll see that it looks like the bottom
figure is what it is basically it looked
like lots of grapes to me large-type
spears and I was so disappointed because
I was used to looking at tiny little
things that were bacteria and I was like
oh my goodness these are huge the
basically the scale bar at the bottom is
10 microns so they're about two or so
and I was used to looking at point four
micron bacteria I did
I talked with hull garnish at Hui about
this and he did point out that that
symbiont Ferno let me show you first i
did find a couple rods so it was it was
promising a little but only a couple I
then talked with Holly Janish and he
explained that many times bacterial
symbionts when they're intracellular
they lose their cell wall because
they're osmotically protected and so
they can they could have very weird
shapes or even just ballooned two
spheres so I had hope
in addition we looked where the blue
arrows are show what looked like
delineation of the host cells and that
we inferred we were testing whether they
were actually intracellular or not as
well so another line of evidence that I
went after next was examining whether
these spheres had DNA and to do this I
used FP fluorescence microscopy using a
stain called a P and this brings me back
to my work with John hobby so I thought
if these spheres had DNA then I would
have another line of evidence and indeed
as you can see in my notebook these
these are a high did all of my
microscopy which is by drawing you can
see these spheres and I have notes that
they're about one to two microns two
microns and that they stained with Dappy
indicating that they have DNA so this is
another line of evidence I also to
control to check the size took a
scraping of my cheek cell which you see
in the lower side of this notebook page
and it turns out that the nuclei were
about 10 to 12 microns so I had another
line of evidence that the these things
the grapes were bacteria but the some of
the more definitive work came with
transmission electron microscopy this is
where you take thin sections through
tissue and it actually shows the ultra
structure of the of the internal
organelles and organs and indeed these
look like bacteria so the bacteria are
labeled e in this slice through the
trophy psalm and they have a typical
size and morphology and if you look at
the panel on the right they have the
typical cell envelope of gram-negative
bacteria those inner tube lines and then
an outer membrane that's inferred to be
that of the host and indicating that
they are within the cytoplasm but
separate so taken together all of these
data along with work by other
researchers which had shown that there
are enzymes associated with
chemosynthetic bacteria in the trophy's
own tissue and other data we concluded
that this is a symbiosis between these
giant tubeworms and that they form
associations with sulfur oxidizing
chemosynthetic bacteria they have not
yep and cultured they fall within the
gamma proteobacteria determined by DNA
sequencing and there has been lots of
research on these which I heartily
suggest you look at in general they're
shown to have many many adaptations to
the symbiosis which include of course
being Malthus and godless they're being
fed internally but also biochemistry
that red you see in the plume is a is a
hemoglobin and it's unique and that it
binds sulphide and oxygen in separate
locations our ahima clomid is poisoned
by by sulphide but here they managed to
deliver both compounds to the bacteria
separately so given this sort of
symbiosis and the benefits accrued to
both it's a nutritional symbiosis the
worms get a nutrition internal nutrition
they're able to live in areas that they
don't need photosynthetic food and the
bacteria which I have with my bacterial
centric point of view benefit because
they get compounds that for energy
generation from both anoxic and oxic
environments advanced the sulphide is
produced geothermally but the oxygen is
in the overlying seawater and the the
bike colonizing an animal coevolution
adaptations the animals practice is
bringing these sulfide an oxygen to
these bacteria given the benefits for
both I would predict and did that things
would be everywhere not just at vents
but in sediments that also like muds
that have sulfide so you can imagine my
delight when a paper was published in
may only two months after I started work
on the tube worms entitled godless by
valves they must have chemosynthetic
symbiotic they were Mouse less and
gutless and they lived in sulfide rich
muds and there was a Condor in Woods
Hole right off the coast I had already
planned to be in Woods Hole that summer
working on another project but I
completely switched and moved down and I
have another fortuitous event and that
is that holy Aisha is microbial
diversity core
at the Marine Biological lab was
focusing on sulphur because of the vents
and he had the sulphur microbiology
dream team which included of course
Holger high schoo Ninh yahuda Cowan and
Yan gal Chuck and effectively I moved in
to learn about sulfur bacteria and as
you can imagine I was trying to figure
out how to find a 1 micron 2 micron size
bacterium inside of a one and a half
centimeter long animal I didn't have
elemental sulfur as a clue where to look
but fortunately hi SKU Ninh pointed out
that Rubisco the car the co2 fixing
enzyme of the Calvin cycle which is
unique to plants and autotrophic
bacteria could be used as an assay for
localizing what tissue bacteria might be
in and indeed the guilt issue of these
animals had very high activities of
Rubisco as you can see in this graph and
indeed with transmission electron
microscopy was able to show that there
are rod-shaped bacteria living within
the gill epithelial cells and the
close-up shows that they have the
typical gram-negative cell envelope and
these two are included in what appears
to be a host membrane direct counts of
these indicated there are 10 to the
ninth to 10 to the 10th bacteria per
gram of tissue and they also have
enzymes associated with sulfur
metabolism and fixed co2 depending on
various sulfur compound additions so we
concluded indeed that this also was a
symbiotic association with chemo
autotrophic the sulfur bacterium since
then we've done a lot of molecular
characterization they are gamma
proteobacteria and while there are
strain level differences it appears to
be a monoculture so again a very
specific symbiotic association the
discovery of chemosynthetic bacteria in
the tissues of Sola Mya also helps
explain a rather peculiar behavioral
aspect they produce Y shaped burrows and
hang out right at the apex of the Y this
had been suggested to either be a
refugium from predators or perhaps they
were gardening bacteria within the the
tubes
however these symbiosis explains why
they would do this they're pumping
oxygen from above from the overlying
seawater and sulfide from below in the
sulfide rich sediments so they're
creating the habitat that the bacteria
need and flowing sulfide an oxygen over
their gills the bacteria fix co2 feed
the animal the animal is feeding the
bacteria so here we had two examples one
at the vents and one in reducing
sediment just coastal sediments and this
indicated to me indeed that these must
be everywhere and it turns out that all
of the major macro fauna at the deep sea
hydrothermal vents have chemosynthetic
symbionts this includes the bivalves the
vent mussels and the giant clams and
also shrimp which instead of having
intracellular bacteria actually have
them on their surfaces epi bonds further
when I and many researchers around the
world looked at other organisms that
live in sulfide rich muds found these
symbiosis with alig Achatz with
nematodes and with colonial ciliates and
indeed the picture that looks like a
rope that is a nematode and all of the
the filaments on top are actually the
bacteria so again these are on the
outside so this hopefully demonstrated
that these chemosynthetic symbiosis are
extremely widespread in nature they
occur in habitats at the interface of
oxic and anoxic environments such as the
vents and sediments and all I've told
you about here is the discovery phase
there has been a lot more research
continuing on these various various
symbiosis ranging from genome sequencing
to looking at optimal growth at deep-sea
pressures and chemical gradients and
I'll just point out as again bacteria
centric given the remarkable remarkable
metabolic breadth of microbes
I predict that there will be many men
other symbiotic associations not just
with chemosynthetic bacteria but with
others that have diverse metabolisms
that would be advantageous to animals
and other eukaryotes that cannot achieve
these sorts of processes and on that
note as I challenge my students both in
class and in the lab expect a discovery
thank you